hey what's going on ladies and gentlemen
I have a major spoiler update for you
guys right now just a few minutes ago
watches on the wall broke some new news
that is a major bombshell and I'm
actually at work right now but I dropped
everything so that I could report on
this news and get it out to you guys as
soon as possible so I apologize if the
audio isn't the greatest I'm actually
using my cell phone right now but let's
get right into it because this is very
exciting as most of you know Game of
Thrones has been in production for
several months as they've been filming
their seven-season of their hit series
and today Watchers on the wall has
reported that the Game of Thrones
production team has returned to a
filming site in Canada that they used a
film wolves against the green screen
which they later enlarge and turn into
dire wolves the company that they used
to produce the dire wolves is called
instinct animals for film and just a few
days ago instinct wolves posted a few
photos on their Instagram account that
are very interesting the first photo
says ready to work and it had a picture
of a white dire wolf whose name is
Quigley this dire wolf has played ghosts
since 2015 and it appears that they are
in production in creating new scenes
most likely for ghosts during season
seven but that is in the most important
news right now
instinct wolves posted another photo to
their Instagram account of a different
dire wolf that looks awfully familiar if
you ask me take a look for yourself and
look at the hashtags this dire wolf
absolutely looks like it can stand in
for a night Mary oh and seeing them use
the hashtag winter is coming has me very
excited about this but that isn't even
the greatest news that it came out today
guess who else showed up in Canada at
the exact same time this company is
creating these dire wolf scenes Maisie
[ __ ] Williams that's right ladies and
gentlemen Arya Stark has arrived in
Canada during the same time instinct
animals for film is creating these dire
wolf scenes now of course all of this
could be a coincidence but I highly
doubt it
I absolutely believe this new dire work
that they are using is going to be nine
mariya and I don't know about you guys
but this news is absolutely incredible
and I pray to the seven gods that all of
this is true which I believe it is I
have always felt that we would
eventually see Nymeria again since they
never actually had a death scene with
her on the show and now that Arya Stark
is in the river
Lan's i 100% believe arias start will
reunite with our direwolf Nymeria again
and i think this is exactly why Maisie
Williams has arrived in Canada to meet
with this production company to film a
scene or even multiple scenes with
Nymeria and according to the plot leaked
it did say that Arya Stark would
encounter her dire wolf again while she
is on her way back to Winterfell
and considering most of the plot leak
appears to be coming true through photos
and reports then there's really no
reason for me not to believe that this
could happen - this has me very excited
and I can't wait to see what you guys
have to say about this so comment below
and give me your thoughts on this news
with Maisie Williams arriving in Canada
while this company Instinct animals for
film is their filming and posting images
like this to their instagram using the
hashtag winter is coming i definitely
believe we will see this happen next
season so comment below and tell me your
thoughts about this new news also don't
forget to check the link in the
description that way you can enter the
giveaway there's only about a week left
until the winner is announced so if you
haven't signed up already then
definitely check the link out in the
description of all of those steps that
way you can have a chance to win the
complete Game of Thrones series on
blu-ray
thank you all for stopping by and
watching this video I appreciate the
support and feedback and as all these
guys I will see you in the comment
section bye